f chappuis est physiothérapeute et
l'offre maintenant ses soins à distance
en télé réadaptation rose ou de films
on est capable de s'adapter
effectivement en entier on n'a pas le
choix notre priorité nous c'est de
pouvoir répondre aux besoins des
patients malgré cette crise là si c'est
une urgence
les physiothérapeutes peuvent
exceptionnellement rencontré aux
patients en personne j'avais une
patiente la semaine dernière que ta
ville qui avait pris les coups penchée
vers l'avant pencher sur le côté depuis
toujours comme ça peut-être pas dormir
mais pour l'ensemble des patients tous
les traitements se font dorénavant par
vidéoconférence vidéoconférence la télé
à la passion existé par le passé mais
c'était surtout pour venir en aide aux
patients qui peut pas se déplacer ou qui
habitez loin
maintenant on réalise qu'on peut
utiliser ça avec tout le monde comment
la clientèle c'est ainsi c'est beaucoup
de gens qui se blessent en faisant du
télétravail des gens qui ont un peu
réorganiser leur façon de travailler
puis se sont fait ma fille quand même si
même si on travaille à la maison puis on
est confiné
c'est le cas de dell film qui souffre de
douleurs persistantes aux poignets là ça
fait à peu près un mois que sucer mois
en télétravail et puis clairement je
pense que mme émond a justement de de
travail d'ordinateurs étaient pas
adéquat puisque ça va créer des douleurs
mais là à la de la caméra j'étais
capable de voir comment elle était
positionnée chez elle et le jeu lui
donner plusieurs conseils sur quels sont
les ajustements qu'elle pouvait faire
puis par la suite on peut établir un
programme d'exercices avec le passé
alors on peut enseigner les exercices
aussi comme ça à distance
en plus de pouvoir offrir toute une
gamme de soins la télé réadaptation
permet à la clinique de maintenir une
certaine clientèle
on en a pas beaucoup je dirais que là
c'est à peu près 10 à 15 pour ça les
patients ont convoyé avant mais j'ai
l'impression que il n'y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui connaissent l'existence la
télé ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal